Speaker 1: Welcome to the show, everybody. We
have a bunch of different covid news to go over
and so many different things. Glad you're with us.
Going to be a very, very full week to start with.
We are potentially just minutes, hours, maybe a
day from full FDA approval for the Pfizer covid-19
vaccine. This is important not only
from the standpoint of medical, but also
because of how this may or may not impact anti
VAX individuals who have been saying as soon as
there's full approval, not emergency use, I will
go and get myself vaccinated. And I've expressed
skepticism that all of the people saying that are
actually going to do it. But we'll get to that in
a moment. There's a new report from The New York
Times which tells us that the FDA is hoping to
approve the Pfizer biotech vaccine. That's the
two dose regimen relevant because we're already
talking about a third dose, the two dose regimen
of that vaccine. Full approval expected today
if there's a delay, maybe an additional day or
two. So this timeline is on the one hand, it's
later than many people had hoped. There's been a
lot of why is this taking as long as it's taking,
it's also sooner than some of the least optimistic
timelines which we're looking at, you know,
later in the fall or at least into September.
I believe that as far as those antibiotics,
people who have been saying once it's fully
approved, I will go and get vaccinated,
I think that for a significant portion of them,
it was just a talking point. It was just something
that they came up with to say, to make themselves
seem rational, to make themselves appear as though
it's not just unhinged anti Voxer ism. It's once
it's approved, I will go and get vaccinated.
Some of them probably will, but many will just
come up with a new talking point. For example,
if they want to, they'll move the goalposts to
well, it's approved, but it was a very political
approval and it was rushed and influenced by the
Biden administration. So we can't trust the full
approval. I would have gone and gotten the vaccine
if it had been a fair and and reliable approval,
but it was clearly a rushed approval. No evidence
of that. But the reality is some of them are going
to come up with something new. Now, the other
piece of this, the other reason this is important
is that there have been many organizations,
schools, employers, governments, et cetera, that
have been thinking about do we require
vaccination for our customers, for our employees,
for students coming back to campus. Some have
already put in place some of those requirements,
but others have hesitated because after all,
the vaccine is approved under emergency use,
they would feel more comfortable requiring a
vaccine once it is fully approved by the FDA.
So that's the other reality. The requirements and
the mandates are likely to increase significantly
once this vaccine is fully approved, which again
should be later today or potentially tomorrow.
Some people say they are against mandating a
vaccine that's only approved for emergency use.
And so when we have full approval, we're expecting
to also see a number of additional requirements
and mandates. And my guess is that the people in
the anti VAX contingent who have been saying the
problem now is it's not fully approved, are going
to shift to focusing on what they will say are
authority, authoritarian and dictatorial vaccine
requirements once it is fully approved. And the
expectation is there's going to be a lot of
them. There are some hospitals and universities
that are expected to mandate vaccination
once the full approval hits. The Pentagon
said earlier this month that they are planning
to make covid vaccines mandatory for the roughly
one point three million active duty troops, no
later than the middle of next month, but even
sooner if the FDA grants that full approval, which
we're now expecting any moment now. I mentioned
that this is approval of a two dose regimen. You
might be saying, well, David, hold on. Last week
you mentioned now there's a recommendation
for a third shot at the eight month mark,
but the approval is only for two shots. That's
exactly right. That is the Biden administration
announced you should, at the eight month mark,
start getting yourself a third dose. The the
approval right now that's been submitted
by Pfizer, which was submitted months ago,
is for a two dose regimen. So the expectation is
once this is approved on the two dose regimen, the
Pfizer will immediately submit to the FDA for
expedited approval of that third booster shot and
then we'll see how long that takes. So the bottom
line here is when we looked at the reasons why
those who didn't want the vaccine didn't want
the vaccine, about a third said, I will get it
if and only if it receives a full FDA approval.
That's going to happen. I suspect not a full third
of those who are against the vaccine. Are going to
go and get it once it's approved, I think it will
have an impact how big it will be, I don't know.
Now, one bit of good news recently, by the way,
after a really long period of declines in daily
vaccination in the US and then very slow ascent,
we are now back to three consecutive days with
one million doses per day, with roughly about 575
thousand people each day being newly receiving one
dose. That's very good news. Two hundred million
Americans have now received at least one dose
of the vaccine. And in terms of what would work
to better incentivize people to go and
get vaccinated, remember that when Joe
Biden encouraged a New York City announced 100
bucks, if you go and get yourself vaccinated,
the 100 bucks didn't really seem to be very
influential to people. And there was a poll done.
And the most effective hypothetical requirement
requirement was if you needed a vaccine to fly,
41 percent of anti vaccine said they would go
and get themselves vaccinated. That seems to be
a really big deal. And then as we're going to
talk about a little bit later on in the program, I
suspect that if you made copays 50 percent instead
of 20 bucks, like imagine you have insurance where
your co-payment is. Twenty dollars or maybe in the
emergency room, maybe in the E.R., you know, it's
200 dollars, 300 dollars if you make it 50 percent
coinsurance if you're not vaccinated, meaning if
you're not vaccinated and you need to go to the
hospital for covid, you pay 50 percent, no more
copay. I think a ton of these people would go and
get themselves vaccinated. It's not clear anything
like that is on the horizon. But needless to say,
I think it's something that would very much work